[Music]
when we go to a supermarket we always
buy things using standard values in
other words we always take one kilogram
of rice or 200 milliliters of fruit
juice fruits are sometimes counted using
the unit dozen one dozen means 12 of
something these are terms used in
everyday life but what if I want to
measure something in terms of the number
of tiny particles present in it let me
explain this in detail looking at this
pure gold can you tell me how many gold
atoms are present in this or wait
looking at this glass of water can you
tell me how many water molecules are
present in it you will probably say that
it's practically impossible to calculate
the number of atoms or molecules in
these examples but astonishingly
chemistry has an answer to this as well
that brings us to the concept of mole
what does it mean it's very easy one
mole of anything has six point zero to
two times 10 raised to 23 atoms or
molecules or particles present inside it
isn't this number huge if I have to
write down the zeros this is how big the
number will look one mole of anything
has these many particles now let's say
we take a substance which has three
times a number of particles here then we
say that this is 3 moles of this
substance and what if we have a
substance which has 8 times the number
of particles here that's correct it will
be 8 moles of that substance that's the
basic concept of a mole of any substance
let's see if you've understood the
concept well now here's one mole of this
pure gold how many atoms does it have
yes as it's one mole it will have 6.02
times 10 raised to 23 atoms in it
similarly one mole of pure water will
have 6.022 times 10 raised to 23 water
molecules inside it so is this how we
define one mole 6.022 times
ten raise to twenty three atoms or
molecules or particles well that's the
simplest way to understand it that means
if we take for example a bag containing
six point zero to two times 10 raised to
twenty three hydrogen atoms then can we
say it's one mole of hydrogen yes that's
right
similarly six point zero to 2 times 10
raised to 23 molecules of any compound
like copper sulfate is one mole of
copper sulfate simple isn't it
wait we have just understood the concept
of mole in simple words but we are yet
to take a look at the scientific
definition of one mole and what's this
number we refer to does it have a
special name watch our next video to
know more
[Music]